heute ist mir erst mal ein mega stein
vom herzen gefallen tatsächlich der
mensch dem ich am 6 märz begegnet bin
er ist negativ also ein qubit 19 ich bin
total happy
und ja der ein oder andere hat sich
gewundert warum hat christoph jetzt sein
bart so komisch abrasiert und dafür gibt
es einen besonderen grund den zeige ich
jetzt mal ja das ist ja eine ffp zwei
maske und die habe ich mir schon vor
einigen wochen besorgt
ja weil ich mehr damals schon gedacht
habe das ist halt so kommen wird und die
muss dicht abschließen also hier würde
ich sie kurz ihr unter die brille hier
oben und unten muss er hat mit dem
kinder abschließen ansonsten bleibt halt
und ich will man ja im bad hat kommt
halt alles mögliche durch die ist
ziemlich dicht hat den vorteil dass von
dem filter eingebaut ist der sich halt
nicht so schnell durchfeuchtet wie bei
anderen masken das hier ist halt
wirklich ein optimaler schutz und habe
ich damals noch zum ganz normalen
preisen bekommen
heute wird so etwas ja wie gold
gehandelt ja und morgen habe ich mein
letztes brot frisches brot vom bäcker
gegessen das heißt es ist zeit für die
brot backt maschinen und selber frisches
brot zu machen und das ist echt so
simpel und deswegen finde ich halt und
maschine richtig klasse auf dem pause
auf instagram hat sich gewünscht dass
ich mal zeigen wie das geht und ja das
ist relativ einfach man öffnet die hier
hat man so einen trog drin mit einem
rührwerk zum kneten
hipster macht schon das mache ich mal
hier nicht ab nein sie ist noch mal vom
strom ab sekunde hat er denn jetzt hier
gemacht
nix nix nix ich gehe einfach mal durch
die programme tut sich nichts tut sich
nix sich nichts ja endlich erwähnt das
ist super einfach das zu bedienen also
moment erscheint hier so eine komische
blinkende anzeige und das ist eigentlich
hier weil man dieses desire uhr hier
sieht oder sanduhr sanduhr müsste dass
hier was mit dieser zeit zu tun haben
aber dass delay das heißt man kann sagen
ich starte erst in 15 minuten stunden
ich weiß es nicht
jetzt will ich hier das irgendwie nix
mehr
doch wunderbar so jetzt steht alles
wieder richtig dort die backzeit steht
dort für dieses programm hüppes 13
minuten und 10 im drei stunden und zehn
minuten
so und jetzt kommt der entscheidende
vorgang
diese backmischung schüttet sie eine
erste was hat 320 millimeter wasser
kommt jetzt hier rein
jetzt kommt die backmischung dazu
was übrigens ein mehr korn brot als
suchworte sonst hoffe ich zumindest
und jetzt drücke ich auf und es bildet
ja später gucken wir dann mal in der
nächsten folge was daraus wird und
ansonsten ist dann bleibt dran
[Musik]